et et 60 de l'indépendance aux deux
visages le film de benjamin stora et de
jean michel meurice un film et une
période qu'on connaît assez mal et sur
laquelle bien sûr on va revenir en
longueur avec benjamin stora qui étaient
avec nous mais nous parlerons aussi de
l'algérie d'aujourd'hui assez discrète
sur l'agitation au proche-orient et dans
le maghreb sur ses printemps arabe qui
ont vu tour à tour la tunisie l'egypte
la libye vivre leur révolution alors que
le syrien assad lui se cramponne à son
pouvoir
en séries alors pour parler de tout cela
et bien benjamin stora qui te
réalisateur du film et qui est historien
auteur de la guerre d'algérie expliqué à
tous au seuil de la guerre d'algérie vu
par les algériens chez denoël enfin qui
nous explique depuis des années comment
comprendre cette crise et cette
révolution algérienne
claude dos mais elle vous vous êtes un
sénateur socialiste des alpes de haute
provence et ça avec des cigales et tout
ça et tout ça beaucoup de chance d'être
là bas et vous vous êtes le président
vous êtes membre président résidents du
groupe d'amitié france algérie et au
sénat oui voilà smaïl goumeziane vous
êtes ancien ministre du commerce
algérien de 89 à 91 université vous avez
écrit algérie d'histoire en héritage aux
éditions non lieu et puis slimane
zeghidour vous êtes journaliste franco
algérien de tv5 monde alors on va
revenir sur ce ne l'est pas comme franco
algérien comme journaliste oui d'accord
à tv5 monde est d'accord tout à fait bon
pourquoi suite d'abord sur côté algérien
parce que ferait bon on a vraiment
l'impression c'est quelque chose qui
fait d'abord pour les algériens avant
d'être fait pour les français
l'originalité de ce film qui a été
réalisé il ya dix ans maintenant
c'était effectivement de montrer la
guerre du côté des algériens jusqu'à
présent france on a énormément montrer
le côté français ce qui est normal bien
entendu mais dans le fond on connaissait
mal les motivations les acteurs les
situations les complexités du côté
algérien et c'était l'objectif de ce
documentaire diffusé il ya dix ans et
sur une période très une période tout à
fait décisive de l'histoire intérieur
algérienne qui est l'histoire du passage
à l'indépendance des luttes pour le
pouvoir et donc la façon dont bien sûr
l'algérie va prendre un chemin qui sera
extrêmement important en rapport avec
cet été 1960
je comprends bien en germe déjà à cette
époque là ce qui va faire l'algérie
d'aujourd'hui
sur ces 50 dernières années puisque l'un
d'eux les intervenants de film dit
quarante ans après on vit toujours
cet effet ya dix ans car on sera prêt on
vit toujours la crise de 62 ans fait
tout y est déjà dans ce paysage et cette
lutte d'influencé entre l'armée et le
pouvoir politique
le personnage qui glissait d'ailleurs
qui est un personnage étonnant important
qu'est ce qui s'appelle salle
apollinaire qui a disparu depuis et qui
effectivement dit nous vivons encore sur
ce qu'il ya sur ce qui s'est produit sur
ses enjeux ses luttes de pouvoir de
l'été 1962 c'est à dire pour aller vite
le problème des rapports entre le
mouvement politique civile et la
question militaire
c'est une question très importante dans
l'histoire intérieur algérien
alors voyons venir parce que ça m'aide
quand même quelques éclaircissements
supplémentaires même si le film est très
bien fait un commentaire comment vous
l'avez vu ressenti ce film découvert ce
sénateur
oui moi je voulais découvrir ce film
hier soir jeu
m'attendais à des moments j'étais un peu
frustré parce que je m'attendais quand
on voyait le départ des ers qui ont aidé
par des pieds noirs je m'attendais à le
voir arriver en france avec les
difficultés qu'ont eue les uns et les
autres pour s'intégrer en fait c'était
pas ça c'était l'histoire algérienne
à l'époque j'avais 22 ans et je suivais
bien sûr l'activité que politique en
algérie comme beaucoup de de france à
l'époque et on sentait très bien qu'il y
avait quelques difficultés en algérie
pour mettre en place le pouvoir
pyongyang qui apparaissait mais j'ai
noté
il y a dans ce film des détails qui sont
fort intéressants et qui permettent de
mieux comprendre ce qui s'est passé à
cette époque là et qui vraisemblablement
explique toute la suite de la mise en
place
les français de leur côté notre mémoire
c'est un petit peu arrêter peu aux
accords d'evian et au rapatriement des
poursuites pour résumer je pense qu'en
france à l'époque j'étais la guerre
d'algérie et terminer enfin c'est que ce
type à l'époque la guerre d'hier qui est
aimé des événements mais j'ai même en
algérie 7e ouf de soulagement
et puis bon ben ce qui se passe en
algérie peut-être lumbala - une sorte de
trou noir sombre il a été géré ces
années là comment vous l'avez ressenti
alors venez découvrir des choses aussi
vous comme ancien ministre ou que
dessine quand même cette histoire
l'appel du ménage
je connaissais cette histoire sauf que
il y à des détails qui sont extrêmement
important parce que les acteurs du film
sont des acteurs de la période et qu'il
explique un certain nombre de détails
que l'histoire de manière générale
ne nous avait pas donné ce qui me semble
également important dans ce film que
j'ai vu également ces derniers jours
c'est que c'est un film qui apprendra
beaucoup aussi à la jeunesse algérienne
les jeunes d'aujourd'hui qui ont moins
de 30 ans connaissent peu voire pas du
tout cette période clé de l'histoire de
l'algérie 1 et ça fait un tabac non
c'est pas ça la fiction française
papa c'est une chaîne française qui l'a
diffusée à l'époque il ya dix ans
c'était france 5 il a été beaucoup vu en
algérie est ensuite placée sur youtube
et donc visionner des dizaines de
milliers de fois sur youtube
essentiellement par des algériens parce
que c'est une histoire que les jeunes
algériens en général connaissent pas
forcément ne connaissent pas forcément
c'est une période à la fois très courte
mais très intense de dison de la guerre
d'indépendance et effectivement cette
partie surtout sur les différents
mouvements qu'il y avait à l'intérieur
de dison du mouvement national lui-même
les contradictions les rivalités etc
tout cela était peu connu tu as des
commentaires à revenir sur le film lui
même
alors moi il ya trois aspects qui m'a
particulièrement frappé dans ce
documentaire
d'abord il y a une énorme quantité
d'image inédite à mon avis sur la liesse
qui a salué l'indépendance que moi j'ai
vécu cette pièce vous étiez bas j'y
étais il ya un avion qui est passé le 19
mars sur le camp de regroupement où
j'habitais il avait fait relancé de
tracts j'ai ramassé un des tracts
j'avais du cessez le feu et j'ai vu
l'ombre des lilas j'avais 9 ans ah oui
donc j'avais vu de l'époque j'avais vu
le délire l'allégresse l'exultation des
gens il y avait des gens n'y avait un
marabout qui était un type hyper réservé
que j'ai vu danser j'ai vu mon propre
père pour la première et dernière fois
de sa vie dans ses passes et le premier
élève vous allez me dire les autres on
va on va revenir sur la dégager près de
2 de faire parler ou de refaire parler
aussi de l'état remette qui décrit sa le
5 juillet et voilà les scènes que la
raconte
c'était un instant de bonheur et surtout
de voir la joie de voir le déferlement
d'enthousiasmé danse c'était
une atmosphère presque magique au
métaphysique
c'était extraordinaire c 'est
c'est surréaliste de voir enfin levé le
voile se mettre en jupe on allait
embrasser les hommes
magico métaphysique 1,10 au sinaï tard
mais je pense qu'il faut comprendre par
là mais ça vous l'avez vécu vous étiez
dans un camp de des regroupements dans
la en petite kabylie c'est est décédé
villageois qui ont été regroupés les
villages ont été désertés par l'armée
française
donc les 6500 habitants du camp avaient
complètement explosé de joie
et quand internet dit qu'il y avait des
femmes qui allait embrasser des hommes
moi j'ai vu des femmes ont lancé des
youyous des maquisards qui descendait du
maquis et les filles se jetèrent leurs
coûts comme les françaises avec les
américains en 45 focus et après ça c'est
le premier élément du documentaire le
deuxième élément j'ai vu à la fois
l'intérêt en même pas une certaine
frustration de voir tellement des
responsables algériens qui ont vécu qui
ont été des acteurs et qui font des
déclarations de première main ne le
faire que parce que un documentariste
est un historien en l'occurrence d'un
jamin stora est allé leur poser la
question c'est à dire que eux mêmes ne
se sentent pas la responsabilité de se
mettre devant un cahier et de noter pour
l'histoire pour l'état certaines ce
qu'ils ont vécu moi un certain nombre et
a comme alerte par exemple boal a écrit
ses mémoires qu'on voit dans le film ali
haroun a écrit ce mémoire qu'on voit
dans le film ait hamouda écrit ses
mémoires qu'on voit dans le film
albé écrit ses mémoires convoi dont il
moque faut nuancer mais bien sûr mais
cela c'est parce qu'ils vivent à
l'étranger et publiés à l'étranger alger
la plupart les gens de ce documentaire
ont été filmés en algérie oui monsieur
la suite à différents degrés
mais je veux dire leurs ouvrages ne sont
pas de diffusion qu'on peut trouver des
126 à alger et voyagistes je sais que
c'est que je trouve bien venir
c'est qui les a droit d'inventer ou un
devoir d'inventaire qui fait sur cette
période là de façon plus ouverte au
niveau des autorités algériennes et du
pouvoir
les autorités mais au moins des acteurs
qu'ils ne sortent leurs archives
personnelles des documents l'état
évidemment l'état n'a pas encore tous
déclassifiés n'est mis à la portée des
historiens et troisième places et de la
documentation bien le troisième point
c'est une phrase de dmd là que je trouve
extraordinaire
il dit une phrase qui paraît
extravagantes mais qui est vrai il dit
au moment où il prend le pouvoir il ay
dans cette révolution il n'y a jamais eu
de pouvoir politique d'autorité
politique c'est à dire une doctrine
politique une autorité qui l'incarné qui
fasse consensus
et il ajoute en servant sa propre
boutique maintenant il y en a une et ça
c'est vrai irène qui est moi oui malgré
lui
c'est ça alors je trouve très bien que
vous nous expliquer un petit peu ce
qu'est le pouvoir pendant cette période
autrement dit quels sont les rivalités
de pouvoir les pôles de pouvoir entre
les maquis entre les historiques entre
le le gouvernement provisoire entre
l'armée comment ça fonctionne et quels
sont les rapports de force on a essayé
avec jean michel meurice
par parenthèse on a fait ensuite dix ans
plus tard un film avec jean michel
meurice qui s'appelle notre histoire et
qui raconte l'arrivée des pieds noirs
des harkis etc
je ferme cette parenthèse qui était
diffusé sur arte donc on a essayé de
simplifier au maximum parce que c'était
très compliqué il y avait des rivalités
personnelles des rivalités de région et
des rivalités entre ceux qui étaient à
l'intérieur de l'algérie ce qui était à
l'extérieur de l'algérie des rivalités
entre ceux qui s'estiment être des
civils d'autres qui étaient des
militaires mais grosso modo il ya trois
centres ben j'ai essayé de simplifier
dans le documentaire
il ya trois centres de pouvoir pour
aller très vite il y a le gpr à un taux
nettement à tunis gouvernement
provisoire la république algérienne
dirigée par d'autres états il y a bien
sûr ce qu'on a appelé l'armée des
frontières avec houari boumediène qui
par enfant aux frontières parce qu'il y
avait eu en 1957 qu'on appelle à l'île
maurice et à dire que la plupart des
gens qui combattait de la ln
progressivement n'ont pas pu rentrer en
algérie donc il y a eu par la ligne
morice
le fait de l'installation à l'extérieur
de l'algérie c'est à dire au maroc et en
tunisie d'un certain nombre disons de
combattants algériens des gens de la lnd
qui a stationné métaireau sinon oui qui
sont restés à l'extérieur et qui
progressivement à partir de 1958 sont
devenus une force militaire organise se
sont organisés en rythme annuel avec
vous mme viel environ une force de 80
mille hommes stationnés aux frontières
qui est une force politique mais bien de
participer part aux combats qui eux se
faisait dans les wilayas de l'est
dans les bacs y sommes d'ailleurs et
donc voilà on en arrive au troisième
grand pôle c'est à dire ces fameux
maquis ces fameuses wilayas de
l'intérieur qui elle avait combattu à
l'intérieur du pays et de la dans ce
film il ya le témoignage exceptionnel
d'effectivement comme le disait c'était
madrid ou le témoignage exceptionnel de
deux personnages qui ont combattu à
l'intérieur de l'algérie tout au long de
la guerre ce qui est très rare 1 c'est
le cas en particulier et de deux salles
à boghni des rebonds on voit tout à fait
à la fin du film les de youssef pratique
et qui a combattu de boutabout à
l'intérieur du pays et ça c'est très
rare aussi donc il y avait plusieurs
pôles et leurs sons l'armée se retire
lorsque les accords d'evian sont signés
et bien ces différents pôles à la suite
d'un congrès dont on peut voir dans
l'est de tripoli
mais on dirait qu est ce que ça discute
est-ce que ça et son laisse que les
wilayas discuter avec l'armée est ce que
l'armée dit souhaiter que gpa et que
pouvoir politique à tunis
bien sûr oui c'est sûr qu'il ya des
circulations qui s'opèrent bien sûr
s'est dit aussi dans le film des
émissaires qui sont envoyées par exemple
en direction des chefs historiques ce
qu'on appelle entre guillemets les chefs
historiques qui eux sont enfermés en bon
petit en france libéré à la suite des
accords d'evian et qui représentait une
charge capital symbolique très fort aux
yeux de la population algérienne bien
entendu donc il ya des émissaires il ya
des circulations il ya toute une série
de discussions qui se mène au maroc par
exemple très important dans lequel ces
discussions avec l'euro à l'époque - un
médecin et puis ensuite à 5 2 qui joue
un rôle très important
y compris en tunisie les discussions
semaine au caire avec nasser bien sûr
dont il ya toute une série de
discussions mais les affrontements quand
même vont éclater les affrontements vont
durer longtemps plusieurs mois pour la
prise du pouvoir tout simplement donc ce
sont des affrontements dans le fond on
pourrait presque dire classique à la
suite d'une guerre révolutionnaire comme
on en trouve très souvent dans les
histoires évolutionnaire zappeur oui
c'est très classique vous le dites moi
je suis pas à mon départ il tournait
finalement quand on voit le film et
qu'on a toutes ces explications
on n'y paraît et tournées de voir qu'il
gare les que toutes ces influences ce qu
est l intérieur de gaieté aux frontières
et le jpg paiera c'est vrai qu'il en
était vraisemblablement un moment où il
fallait choisir et chacun voulant
à -6 puis en province oui les
affrontements étaient d'autant plus
violent dès le lendemain de
l'indépendance que l'aspect politique
sociale dans les débats internes
la guerre était faite était réduite à
des affrontements et à l'aspect
strictement militaire mais ce que les
problèmes de la société de l'état je
pense que deux éléments me semble
expliquer la brutalité et la férocité
les affrontements 1 c'est l'absence
d'une tradition étatique algérienne
c'est à dire que dans l'inconscient de
chacun il n'y avait pas le souvenir d'un
état d'une administration d'un cadastre
d'un état civil et la colonisation
française qui a tout fait pour renforcer
les structures existantes de l'état en
tunisie par exemple et au maroc à
démanteler tout ce qui ressemblait à une
structure étatique en algérie donc
absence de ce lourd qui a rien de sûr il
y aura rien dans la traite dans la
mentalité il n'y avait pas une mémoire
d'un état préexistant à la colonisation
tant il fallait tout de suite remettre
en place les structures
cet élément est là le deuxième élément
c'est l'intériorisation de la violence
coloniale
c'est par les élites algériennes c'est à
dire que la force paye et que l'on sait
par la force qu'on va y arriver
c'est lorsque la présence coloniale
française aussi j'ajoute pour préciser a
duré très longtemps
c'est à dire près d'un siècle et demi
c'est considérable ces trois quatre cinq
six générations
c'est considérable on a du mal à
envisager cela c'est à dire que le
souvenir des disons d'une d'un état
antérieur ou même de ce qui a pu se
passer dans les années 1830 50
un siècle et demi plus tard bien sûr
c'est perdu et tout ça va se détricoter
en très peu de temps on fait très peu de
temps quelques en quelques semaines
quelques semaines l'histoire s'accélère
de manière absolument extraordinaire
alors c'est le gp a le goût d'un
gouvernement provisoire de tunis qui
négocie à evian avec le choc ces fameux
accords d'evian qui vont conduire à
l'indépendance
ensuite il ya l'ouverture des frontières
l'armée rentrer boumédiène c'est que
c'est qu'ils boumédiène quel rapport il
avec benbella qu'est ce qui fait que son
armée
12e c'est un personnage qu'on connaît
très bien maintenant bien sûr mais à
l'époque il était assez peu connue pour
cela il est une anecdote aller quand
j'ai fait le film à lui seul il n'était
pas encore sorti c'est l'extraordinaire
anecdotes racontées par claude lanzmann
dans son livre de mémoires ou je sais
pas si vous avez lu ce passage où il
était à l'époque jeune journaliste il
avait participé à l'écriture d'un
article
il avait mangé à une table où il y avait
effectivement des combattants algériens
aux frontières en tunisie et il y avait
beaucoup viennent comme le responsable
suprême de cette armée mais qui mangeait
comme tous les autres à l'accord il
n'avait pas reconnu
lanzmann n'avait pas reconnu ou bien
certains le côté plaidé ya le côté
populiste le côté paysan le côté austère
aussi qu'ils existent côté très dur de
ce personnage qui va s'imposer
progressivement comme un personnage de
premier plan mais qui n'est pas connu ou
reconnu lé par les autorités politiques
étrangères au plan international celui
qui est le plus connu à l'époque c'est
ben bella donc et s'est racontée dans le
film
boumediene qui fait de la politique déjà
à l'époque c'est que pour accéder au
pouvoir il lui faut un personnage plus
il a la forme mais là la force mais il
n'a pas la légitimité mais il a pas là
disons la reconnaissance historique
internationale et c'est ben bella bien
sûr qui va lui apporter cette
reconnaissance mais boumediene c'est
déjà un personnage bien installé dès les
années 1958 1959 à la suite de toute une
série de coups d'état de complot de
fayat ya toute une histoire très
complexes que l'on compte pas raconter
ici mais il est déjà un personnage en
1960-61 quittant longtemps et très
allantes ya effectivement soixante mille
hommes avec lui à la frontière de
l'algérie alors parlons de cette fameuse
de ce conseil national de la révolution
algérienne ça se passe à tripoli
pourquoi tripoli belge de mons le
demande
c'est la question que se pose le
commandant azzedine responsables de la
ville d'alger qui comprend toujours pas
pourquoi ça c'est parfait tout
simplement en algérie nous n'avons pas
été parce que nous nous étions ici à
alger à faire des choses beaucoup plus
importantes et plus sérieux c'était la
lutte contre l' os faut pas oublier qu'à
l'époque il y avait une centaine de
morts par jour nous aurions bien voulu
nous avons espéré nous avons souhaité
nous avons désiré nous l'avons écrit qu'
au lieu que ce congrès
face à tripoli qu'il se passe à
l'intérieur
le premier congrès de du fln à hélène
s'est fait un voeu août 56 et à
l'intérieur du pays
oui pourquoi le deuxième congrès alors
que nous sommes indépendants ne se
ferait pas à l'intérieur avec avec les
dirigeants coopté tels que moi tel ami
salah un désordre bien sûr qu'ils
assistent élargi aux cadres qui ont été
formés par la révulsion bon alors ce
fameux congrès il est en mai à tripoli
en mai 62 les accords d'evian bien sûr
eu lieu l'algérie est en passe d'être
indépendants qu'elle le sera
effectivement avec le vote
d'autodétermination qui interviendra le
1er juillet 1962 pourquoi ce cours elle
se fait en dehors de l'algérie est à
l'instigation de qui on n'a pas de
réponse à cette question particulière
n'ont toujours pas parce que en fait
c'était le plus petit dénominateur
commun entre tous les acteurs qui
étaient entrés le même en compétition il
fallait se réunir dans un lieu considéré
comme neutre parce que la kula de la
crise couvait déjà de manière très
importante et il fallait sur se réunir
dans un lieu proche de l'algérie mais
qui soit un territoire neutre où on
puisse aussi sweeney leur visa d'être
alger symbolique normale à la fin du
mois de mai 1962
attention alger il y a encore énormément
loi d'attentât il ya énormément de
cheveux d'explosion de meurtre c'est une
ville en foyer comme un mal j en mi juin
62 1 donc c'est très difficile aussi de
tenir un congrès à l'intérieur et je
dirais à cette époque il ya peut-être un
autre élément c'est que l'indépendance
venu mentalement parlant et
culturellement parlant le fln a continué
à fonctionner comme un mouvement de
libération et non plus comme une
structure étatique donc la clandestinité
les lieux périphériques pour se réunir
le secret l'opacité à l'époque a pas
encore intégré le fait que enfin qu'il
avait le pouvoir où il avait dit l'avoir
et non d'aller construire il faut il
continuer de fonctionner comme un
mouvement de libération donc avec toute
la dose de clandestinité de dopage de
cloisonnement voile réalisée en images
par exemple alors qu'ici d'un congrès
fondateur
mais ces comédiens je crois qu'il faut
aussi rappeler un élément important qui
a été dit par le commandant reste digne
c'est que le congrès de la soummam de
1956 a été le congrès de la rupture dans
la dans la guerre de libération
nationale
c'est le moment contrairement à ce que
dit benbella c'est le moment où le
projet politique et mis en place par
abane ramdane et le projet politique ça
veut dire primauté du politique sur le
militaire primauté de l'intérieur sur
l'extérieur et cela à partir de 1956 on
n'en veut pas en tout cas les militaires
ne veulent pas un certain nombre
dirigeants d historique ne veulent pas
et ça finira en décembre 1957 par
l'assassinât d'abane ramdane et donc ce
congrès a été un traumatisme très fort
et il y as probablement de cela aussi
les congrès de l'intérieur on sait ce
que ça a déjà donné en 1952 annoncé ça
y'est fait ça à l'extérieur pour
redonner toujours son importance à
l'extérieur par rapport à l'intérieur tu
as comme il semble que il ya deux dates
le 19 mars le 5 juillet et mais c'est
entre 10 mars le circuit c'était une
période me semble-t-il
après avoir entendu les uns les autres
une période où il y avait beaucoup
d'interrogations sur la suite parce que
faut pas confondre les accords d'evian
et là le 5 juillet qui est
l'indépendance il ya eu beaucoup
d'interrogations il me semble que moi la
réponse que j'ai c'est que on a voulu
tenir à tripoli parce que c'était
sécurisé par rapport à toutes les
interrogations qu'il y avait en algérie
et sur le territoire des attentats une
période un peu difficile donc on est à
lier un endroit sécurisé ix est donc ce
qui va se passer ensuite alors on va
récolter encore un petit extrait du
documentaire ou à la conclusion de ce
congrès c'est que malheureusement il va
pas rien à voir c'était con
jamais voté il va être dissous et il y
aura plus de congrès personne ne savait
que le clash avec tripoli
sauf quelques responsables et puis on
n'était pas arrivé à la confrontation
nous espérions toujours que le cnra qui
avait été dont la séance avait été
suspendue à tripoli aurait été de
nouveau convoqué à alger convoqué alger
et puis comment dirais-je qu'il aurait
terminé sa mission
un aurait on aurait à ce moment-là élu
un bureau politique qui soit l'émanation
de l'ensemble des membres du cnra on
espérait qu'ils allaient se réunir
jusqu'au jour où le 22 juillet 1962
monsieur ben bella a déclaré à tlemcen
le bureau politique c'est moi voilà on
ça se fait comme ça c'est que tout d'un
coup c'est quoi c'est une prise de
pouvoir des jalles benbella avec
boumédiène derrière en disant ça y est
maintenant c'est moi la politique c'est
moi le pouvoir
je pense qu'il ya effectivement une
dynamique qui s'est enclenchée de
manière extrêmement rapide
ce qui a été évoqué tout à l'heure c'est
à dire où la force va l'emporter sur sur
la politique sur la doctrine politique
mais ça va se jouer très vite ses rangs
quelques jours quelques semaines appel
puisque la très vite à 2 par l'ouest
l'armée des frontières va rentrer en
algérie va s'installer club c'est nos
rangs et c est donc on a effectivement
l'installation de fait le rapport de
force en faveur de ce qu'on a appelé
l'armée des frontières qui va porter
littéralement porté m de là mais il ya
des oppositions il ya des oppositions à
les oppositions très violente qui vont
s'exprimer
venant de toute une série de personnages
importants comme ahmed boudiaf krim
belkacem qui ont été des personnages
considérable ce qu'ils ont c'est eux qui
avaient déclenché il avait été parmi les
déclencheurs de cette guerre contre la
france et qui vont entrer en dissidence
s'affronter
je peux pas faire le détail de tout de
tout ces safaris avec moi a eu des
combats bien entendu il ya beaucoup de
moi il ya eu il ya eu des morts il ya eu
des combats dans l'été 1962 devant là
dans la ville de constantine devant la
ville d'alger en particulier dont il
s'oppose à l'avant ça ça permet de
l'extérieur voilà et puis des
affrontements entre wilaya et puis
progressivement progressivement il ya
aussi dans la société algérienne la
nécessité le besoin le désir que la paix
revienne parce que sept ans ça suffit
parce que les gens ont beaucoup souffert
et veulent absolument que s'arrête c'est
conflit meurtrier fratricide pourrait-on
dire
et à partir de stud de la fin du mois
d'août progressivement eh bien c'est ce
tandem qui va de la brienne qui va
prendre le pouvoir est rentré dans
l'alger et c'est là que les choses vont
se passer fier si je puis dire
et la vraie la révolution algérienne
elle se fait comme ça il ya la guerre
contre la france il ya après la
révolution qui se fait avec du sang a eu
des combats avec une opposition qui fout
la terrasse est maîtrisée de la part de
ben bella et de boumédiène il y à un
autre élément c'est que le nouveau
pouvoir qui prend le pouvoir avec donc
le temps d'un bel 1 et boumédiène va
encore se comportait comme un mouvement
révolutionnaire comme un mouvement de
libération est donc privilégiée
l'opacité la khl le secret
le les façades civile avec un pouvoir
plus occulte derrière donc en fait on a
l'impression que culturellement ils ne
sont jamais rentrés dans dans le jeu de
l'exercice étatique qui suppose la
construction d'une mémoire étatiques
dans l'archivage les mêmes courante les
documents la classification des
documents amylie membres de transparence
tout cela les algériennes lundi qu en
tout cas dans cette questionnaire vous
avez cette période vous parce que vous
souvenez de la 5 juillet mais de ça de
cette guerre pour le pouvoir de cette
incertitude là on était inquiet en
algérie alors l'incertitude c'est que
moi j'étais dans un camp de regroupement
dans la montagne et quand la guerre est
terminée nous sommes retournés dans
notre hameau d'origine qu'on n'avait pas
vu depuis sept ans donc nous sommes
arrivés dans le village il ya eu seize
mille villages qui ont été vidés on
revient dans nos villages les ronces et
des broussailles avaient envahi tout le
village
les portes et les fenêtres avaient
disparu d'autres choses à faire et
refaire de la pratique
non surtout on est parti à alger parce
que on fait ce qui s'est passé c'est que
le leadership se battaient à alger pour
le pouvoir met l'algérie rural les deux
millions cinq cent mille déplacés de
l'intérieur qui était dans les camps de
regroupement
personne n'est venu s'en soucier dans
qu'est ce qu'on a fait on est parti à
alger moi je me souviens on est arrivé
au mois d'août 62 à alger je me souviens
d'un discours de ben bella nous
habitions au tangara juste au dessus du
palais du gouvernement et je me souviens
un soir de la voix de ben bella qui
monte il prépare et voilà il lançait son
discours il y avait à peu près deux
phrases en français une obésité belle
bella qui avait les faveurs de ces deux
millions de paysans algeria qui arrivait
sur alger il était il était populaire
mais on n'était pas du tout politiser on
avait juste des posters où il y avait
belle a effectué la drass et bella dans
edenred à y avait il y avait en fait il
y avait des posters où il y avait cinq
ou six figures il est dans l'est pendant
ce qu'on ne pouvait acheter etc ont
collé dans dents
dans les maisons c'est ce danger
rappelle c'est cette atmosphère de
méfiance et de peur alors que j'étais
tout petit il y avait une peur quand
même monsieur roux médias ont été ou à
ce moment là alors moi j'étais en
banlieue parisienne à vous suiviez tout
ça de la banda et donc nous avons fêté
avec le même
le même enthousiasme l'indépendance en
banlieue parisienne pas très loin
d'asnières où j'habitais avec mes
parents puisque je suis un fils de
l'immigration et nous nous avions les
informations par par le courrier ou par
un peu le téléphone à ce moment là et
par la presse mais effectivement ce qui
transpirait au niveau des parents parce
que j'étais jeune également c'était
c'était de l'inquiétude dont les
affrontements en tout cas ça les gens le
savaient et j'ai également souvenir
d'une anecdote en lors c'était
probablement fin 62 ou au niveau de la
fédération de france du fln celle ci
n'existait plus officiellement mais
benbella vais demander à ce que les
migrations en particulier continuent de
cotiser pour pouvoir aider le pays à à
redémarrer et je me souviens d'un voisin
que nous avions que je prenais pour un
ouvrier très tranquille qui était en
fait un commando effet l'aisne à paris
qui a été chargé donc d'aller essayer de
convaincre le bidonville de nanterre de
continuer à cotiser et aux bidonvilles
de nanterre il a été abattu par parent d
une des personnes du bidonville qui lui
a dit ça suffit donc cette heure on ne
sait pas en va l'argent et c'est donc
cette confession l'algeei on les
trouvait un petit peu oui petite vie
chère dans la communauté algérienne en
devant se ce commando qui avait fait la
guerre sans son problème pendant sept
ans a été tuée des mains d'une et en
termes de favori est ce qu'il y avait un
favori ce cas un espoir est que ben
bella était l'homme du recours est
effectivement le dépositaire de toute la
mémoire et de la révolution algérienne
ou est-ce que c'était beaucoup plus que
ça non je crois qu'on en était pas
encore à identifier un
un personnage principal il y avait la
révolution il y avait un certain nombre
de de ce qu'on appelait l'hérault aller
à l'époque c'est vivant global de
savaria les choses avaient tourné
surtout une inquiétude
les gens n'étaient pas prêts parce que
pendant toute la guerre il n'y avait pas
eu d'informations sur ces rivalités ils
découvraient pour la plupart en tout cas
la population découvrait ses rivalités
intestines
il ya d'ailleurs une tradition dans le
système algérien c'est qu'il n'y a
jamais de culte de la personnalité
il y avait ce slogan il n'y avait pas
vraiment de cuir le système est
tellement plus fort le système et la
partie cachée de l'iceberg du système
font que les individus qui pendant
qu'ils sont au pouvoir paraissent tout
puissant mais dès lors qu'il disparaisse
il ne laisse pas de traces il ne laisse
pas de culture il ne laisse pas
d'empreinte je ne sais pas ce faisant
vous en pensez je ne viens pas du tout
la personne s'attache toujours quand
même assez divers qu'on connaît oui qui
laisse des traces qui écrivent des
livres les bonus qui compte c'est
l'appareil qui est derrière
c'est l'appareil qui est derrière je ne
sais pas ce que l'état le pouvoir unique
jamais l'armée oui il n'ya jamais de
culte de la personnalité en algérie
comme le cud qu'il ya eu pour benali
haut pour nasser au pour assad par
exemple alors justement sur le
l'installation je dirais presque
définitif de ce pouvoir puisque l'on a
vu un petit peu cette révolution qui
s'est faite les combats qui ont amené
l'armée de libération nationale et et
ben bella au pouvoir à alger
deux ans plus tard ben bella est déposée
enfin et à coup d'état par mobilières
trois ans plus tard 65 et ça se fait
comment est-ce que c'est là
effectivement que le pouvoir va se
classer pour des dizaines d'années avec
ce parti unique et avec cette arme est
associé à 2 62 65 et une très grande
effervescence à la fois culturelles
politiques mais en même temps un
événement quand même servis
d'interdiction de partie par exemple le
parti communiste algérien est interdite
une guerre en kabylie entre le ffs en
1963 le ffs et le parti de hocine ait
ahmed qui a fait dissidence
donc il ya des oppositions il y à aussi
des manifestations d' autoritarisme qui
s'exerce du pouvoir mais dans la société
algérienne le souvenir qu'on a encore de
cette période est celle plutôt de
l'effervescence culturelle politique où
rien n'est joué che guevara via alger
par exemple en 1964 qui provoque pour
manque aussi un grand enthousiasme lgh
et surtout avait c'était une grande un
grand moment pour les algériens bien
entendu donc alger était un peu la
capitale du tiers-monde en fait en
effervescence à cette époque là et puis
en 1965 il ya une sorte de glaciation
bien sûr qui va s'installer le 19 juin
1965 avec l'arrivée sur le devant de la
scène politique mais de manière ouverte
ce qui n'était pas le cas auparavant
mais de manière ouverte des militaires
et donc la priorité est donnée à partir
de ce moment là à la consolidation la
construction de l'état nation donc de
l'état tout court et d'état autoritaire
au détriment de la possibilité de
l'exercice d'une société civile d'un
pluralisme politique etc
c'est une autre histoire qui va
effectivement commencé en algérie
pratiquement jusqu'en 1988 mais là on
entre dans une autre dans une autre
discussion
c'est à dire le fait que le fln va
disparaître en fait comme parti
politique à partir de 65
l'armée veut devenir toute puissante le
fln c'est simplement une vitrine et les
partis politiques n'existe plus en tant
que tel donc c'est 1965 jusqu'au
jusqu'aux années 80 il ya effectivement
ce sentiment de l'unanimisme ce
sentiment effectivement à la société que
pour les villes qui a été quand même
rompu par en 1981 parce qu'on a appelé
le printemps berbère
c'est à dire non à soulèvement en
kabylie qui introduit le désir de
pluralisme et de démocratie politique de
manière incontestable et qui va ensuite
s'épanouir encore de manière encore plus
fort agréable à partir d'octobre 1940 et
l'arrivée du multipartisme et l'arrivée
du multiple n'est pas classée à la
soviétique c'est vrai à cette différence
majeure près c'est qu'on union
soviétique l'armée et les services
secrets
obéissez au gouvernement civil là non
c'est l'armée qui décide c'est ni riche
dessine et or à l'union soviétique
mais rouge était sous le contrôle du
soviet suprême et du bureau police et
l'armée qui décide qui peut être chef de
l'état qui fait les élections en algérie
l'armée était réputé avoir tous les
pouvoirs
et alors qu'on union soviétique parce
qu'on fait souvent la comparaison avec
l'union soviétique mais en ligne non
sollicités le pouvoir c'est être
gouvernés audit était c'est plus le cas
du tout ah non je ne sais pas si c'est
tout à fait le cas mais en tout cas elle
avait cette réputation que là évidemment
l'armée en algérie est antérieure à la
construction de l'état
l'armée a été construite avant l'état et
elle a été construite dans la
clandestinité avec une culture de
cloisonnement de se créer des pas cité
dans le monde avait un pseudonyme dans
les rues quarantaine ne serait pas votre
vie mais vous restez en algérie moi j'ai
la green hill puis quand tu vois moi je
vis en france depuis 40 ans et vous êtes
parti pour quoi pour ces raisons là
parce que en eau non plus long je suis
parti j'avais 20 ans je voulais voir le
monde
d'abord parce que là j'ai vu de l'époque
était un pays très cosmopolite
contrairement à aujourd'hui qui brassait
de l'esprit brocante islamiah ji est et
la capitale où tous les révolutionnaires
du monde entier venaient j'ai vu à alger
angela davies cette année car michael
miriam makeba eldridge cleaver c'était
une ville hyper qu'il y avait un espoir
fou sur ce qui allait naître la haye
avait avant il y avait une
mais gervais sens culturel la suite
après que l'armée ait un tout ça
monsieur vos médias
je crois que
effectivement les choses se sont fait
dire consolidé cristalliser à partir du
coup d'état de 1965 avec quand même
en tout cas c'était perçu comme cela à
ce moment là la volonté affichée de
boumédiène à la fois de construire un
état
parce que effectivement le disais tout à
l'heure là la seule institution qui
existait avant l'indépendance c'était
l'armée il n'y avait pas de détails
construit et c est donc les bribes
d'état ottomans avaient été détruits
pendant la longue période coloniale
est ce qu'il faut dire donc c'est que
boumédiène a voulu construire un état
fort
ta autoritaire pour éviter donc les
batailles politiques que le
multipartisme ou d'autres systèmes
mettrait en jeu et il a aussi très vite
compris l'importance de répondre aux
besoins des populations notamment de la
paysannerie en essayant de se lancer
dans un vaste programme de développement
basé sur l'industrialisation à lens
c'est important parce que il n'ya pas
que l'aspect pouvoir il ya effectivement
une volonté de changement
ensuite vous avez des milliers serein
entre 89 et 91 printemps arabes on va
dire printemps algérien
c'était un multipartisme et ouverture de
la société politique algérienne à un peu
plus de diversité on va dire je passais
les deux façades cette ouverture
s'ils étaient réels mais vous en avez
profité entre guillemets est ce que
c'est pour ça que l'algérie n'a pas vécu
ce qu'ont vécu ses voisins n'a pas vécu
ces fameux printemps arabe aujourd'hui
pas le ce que nous nous avons appelé à
ce moment là le printemps démocratique a
été effectivement une véritable lame de
fond au niveau de la société algérienne
par rapport au système qui avait été mis
en place depuis 1962 il faut savoir
comme disent on le disait benjamin stora
tout à l'heure que on est passé d'une
situation de monopole dans tous les
domaines de l'activité économique et
sociale du pays à une période de
libération progressive non seulement au
niveau politique avec
avènement du multipartisme au niveau
économique avec la destruction des
monopoles d'état public qui
verrouillaient l'ensemble du champ
économique avec la liberté de la presse
en 1990 ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
encore l'algérie peut s'enorgueillir
d'avoir une des presses les plus
indépendantes du monde arabe et etc etc
est ce cette lame de fond dont on
pourrait expliquer les disons les
raisons au niveau de la crise du système
depuis des années 80 a été brutalement
freinée et bloquer alternance avec
l'arrivée du fils parce que nous nous
c'est plus compliqué que l'armée c'est
un système ecf read our disais tout à
l'heure au pack il y à des militaires il
y à des civils c'est beaucoup plus
complexe il ya de l'intérieur il y adeux
l'extérieur en tout cas ce système a
bloqué le printemps démocratique de
l'algérie et ensuite il s'est trouvé
confronté à une opposition politique
beaucoup plus violente qui devient
ensuite une opposition terroristes qui
arrivent là des islamistes à une
histoire qu'on connaît un peu mieux
puisque ce l'arrivée des islamistes
c'est ce scrutin qui est prêt de les
amener au pouvoir
c'est l'armée qui intervient et c'est
cette guerre civile qui va durer dix ans
qui va faire deux cent mille morts une
non je crois pas de sentiments sans fin
entre 100 et 105 100 à 150 morts il aura
un sit in en vain qu'elle était sa
légère physiquement ils n'ont bon et
aujourd'hui il nous resterait deux
minutes mais aujourd'hui on a vu aussi
ollier minéraux elle qui a été
démissionné par l'armée en 99 on a vu
arriver
monsieur bouteflika et c est ce que
l'armée est toujours le faiseur de roi
si je puis dire en algérie où est ce que
les choses se démocratise un peu plus un
mot pour dire que si la question des
printemps arabes actuelles par rapport à
l'algérie c'est le traumatisme de la
guerre civile intérieur des années 90 et
donc des dizaines de milliers de morts
qui fait que quand il ya une hésitation
à par rapport à la mémoire disons du des
années 88 92 qui a débouché sur des
affrontements terrible entre l'armée et
les islamistes qui fait hésiter une
fraction de la société algérienne par
peur disons de la répétition mais ça ne
veut pas dire pour autant qu'ils
recevraient de conflits de révolte de
france
la société aja est restée prudente en
disant cela on n'y va pas mais c'est à
dire qu'il ya eu deux guerres en 30 ans
en algérie quand même sens lors de
guerre en 30 ans la guerre
d'indépendance 55 62 et puis cette
guerre civile de 92 2 me avant 2002 pour
aller vite je sais plus bon ces deux
guerres en 30 ans est considérable sur
une société avec des centaines de
milliers de morts à chaque fois
c'est des déplacements de populations
slimane zeghidour parlais tout à l'heure
la population des ruraux pendant la
guerre d'indépendance mais il ya eu
aussi des placements des ruraux dans les
années 90 absolument on dirait un énorme
déplacement des pays de la paysannerie
donc tout ça pour dire que il ya
effectivement cette hésitation
alors maintenant le système est ce que
le système pour autant sortir de ces de
cette dernière guerre ce dernier
affrontement
ça changeait pas véritablement donc les
enjeux démocratiques restent à l'ordre
du jour dans un pays comme l'algérie
notamment au niveau de l'exercice des
libertés publiques etc
alors on va fêter les 50 ans en algérie
ça qu'en tant que cette révolution quand
même en fin de set l'accès à
l'indépendance
est-ce que ça va être une grosse fête ou
est-ce que ça va être assez discret de
ce que je sais c'est qu'il n'y a rien de
particulier
5 juillet alors est ce qu'il ya une
explication à cela
peut-être que le pouvoir veut pas
particulièrement fêté cette indépendance
une manière plus solennel
peut-être parce que de 50 ans après on
fait le bilan et les pas bons je suis
pas en tout cas on n'a pas envie de le
faire de façon trop ostensible et que
c'était l'occasion de se poser d'abord
convaincre discrétion c'est un début de
cette discrétion qui a commencé il ya à
peu près 30 ans par exemple gérard
souviens quand on était enfant il y
avait là le grand défilé du 1er novembre
donc
anniversaire du déclenchement de la
guerre d'indépendance il y avait sur le
front de mer un défilé d'un cortège de
10 km pendant toute une journée avec
passage d'avions d'hélicoptères de
parachutistes bref il y avait ce défilé
mais depuis fait des trente ans il n'y a
plus cette ses carnets ces militaires
ces démonstrations de force du souvenir
de gloire nationale et donc il y aura
pas a priori de grandes festivités pour
les 50 ans de l'indépendance algérienne
comme si le pouvoir se méfier quelque
part je pense c'est le cas de ce qu'il
pouvait se passer à stockage en avant de
la lui merci en tout cas on aurait voulu
parler davantage encore de l'algérie
d'aujourd'hui mais c'était déjà
passionnant de préciser comment se sont
cristallisées les choses il ya
maintenant 50 ans merci à vous tous
merci à ohrid à face qui a préparé ce
débat je vous rappelle notre adresse
internet si vous voulez nous nous écrire
que et vous dire que la semaine
prochaine et bien on parlera de la
conquête de l'espace voilà je vous
laisse bien sûr sur puis cela pour unis
passé une belle semaine
ouais